today's one minute monday is support
someone find someone in your network who
you can help today so here's a quick
story
i work with an agent and this guy
represents a whole bunch of thought
leaders and a lot of them are trying to
make videos and he brought in a new
client and i checked out one of her
videos and she's just getting started
but i liked the video and so i gave it a
thumbs up on youtube and and i left a
comment on it saying that i liked it and
i did that because i remember when i was
first getting started and nobody left
any comments and i was barely getting
any views and i felt like i was pouring
my heart into something and nobody cared
about it and she's in that same spot now
where you know not getting a lot of
comments on the on the videos not
getting a lot of views i remember when i
got a comment i felt so good like yes
somebody cares
and so today i got to be that somebody
for her and give her a little bit more
energy and motivation and a boost so
support the people in your network it'll
make you feel good it'll make them feel
good and it will help your business as
well
believe
you